the Joe Rogan experience right how did
we get here
it's 20/20 we are facing a global
pandemic which incidentally I do want to
talk to you about okay we are facing a
global pandemic we are facing rioting in
the streets a movement that's showing
signs of a Maoist challenge to the most
fundamental aspects of the West right
and we're gonna have to choose between
Donald Trump and Joe Biden what neither
one of these people is capable of or
inclined towards the kind of leadership
that you have just described we would
need the grade so that means at a very
at the very least if we do not divert
our course right if November comes and
we are choosing between those two then
that means we're putting off any
solution at least for years because the
president the president would be
essential to changing our course right
and this is just built into these
parties now right Obama I can't figure
out why it's the case I really like
Obama personally he seems like the right
guy to me but his his administration at
a at a policy level is indistinguishable
from Bush in some ways it was worse so
what we've got is parties that decide
what we get to choose from and the game
is to prevent us from having any choice
that could possibly solve the problem so
we have to fix that we have to address
that problem and we have to break their
stranglehold and you know in fairness
Trump was a challenge to that two-party
duopoly he's not really a Republican
right right but he's also not really an
alternative it's like a third crime
family right yeah you've got the
Republicans the Democrats and now they
sort of co-opted their ideology to fit
his needs
yeah but it's not a solution right so we
have to get that solution which means we
have to get by the parties Trump proved
that was possible right I think if
there's any road
there was ever a time where an
independent party has a chance now is
the time if someone steps in and has a
real solution and also for in terms of
the distribution of that information and
now's the time because you could just
post something on YouTube where you're
demonstrating like through a
step-by-step process you could take
hours to do it like this is what I want
to do and this is how I'm gonna do it
you break those down the clips almost
like a podcast and if someone was a
person of substance that we really
believed in and we said that person can
really do this this actually could
happen let's vote independent it could
happen they don't have a monopoly on the
distribution of information anymore
and that's terrifying to them because
they used to be able to count on the
shills on the left and the right to get
the word out for them but they don't
have that anymore you have so many
people that really don't have an
ideological foundation in either one of
them that are talking and they're
reaching millions of people that's a
rare moment in time and this is in my
opinion the very best time for someone
to step in that's not they're not
compliant they're not they don't have to
give it they don't they don't need that
policy machine behind them or the
political machine behind them well I've
got a plan okay but we would have to
find a really big podcast I think to get
enough momentum to see none of those out
there you haven't encountered a big
party no they don't exist
all right you wanna hear the plan sure
okay the rock and jockle willing well
you know let's put that okay let's put
that to the side it's not part of the
plan but it actually could fit okay so
here's the the plan this plan needs a
better name but the working title is the
Dark Horse duo plan and the plan looks
like this we draft two individuals we
find two people one of them is
center-left
and one of them is center-right and
these people have to have certain
characteristics a minimum set they have
to be patriotic they have to be
courageous and they have to be highly
capable right but that's it okay
center-left in a center right and we
pair them together
and we draft them with the following
plan that they will govern as a team
that is to say every important decision
will be discussed and they will decide
what to do as a team and only in cases
where they cannot reach agreement or
whether something has to be whenever
something has to be decided on a very
short timescale like a military decision
does the person who inhabits the role of
the president govern alone okay we draft
these folks and then four years down the
road they switch and the one who had run
for president now runs for the vice
presidential spot and the one who was
vice president now runs for president
and they continued this way until one of
two things happens either we vote
someone else in or one of them has
inhabited the office of president twice
and is no longer eligible and then that
person has to be replaced so we have a
patriotic team governing together
from center left and center right when
you say drafted that's the problem like
someone has to be motivated to ruin
their [ __ ] lives to try to run this
country well that's what happens to
everybody that does it I agree but then
that's an obstacle you're spelling out
or an obstacle that I would argue is
solvable that we know these people who
okay so okay let's just to say that's
the plan so far you can talk about what
problems it solves as much as you want
you're welcome to but okay so here's my
proposal so the plan could be right and
my proposal for who we draft could be
wrong and I'm happy to see other people
swapped in okay but my proposal would be
Admiral William McRaven
on the right you know who that is no I
don't okay he is a Navy SEAL former Navy
SEAL he was until 2018 the Chancellor of
the University of Texas he is a very
cogent center-right Republican he was
the lead on the bin Laden raid and he is
I think universally respected by people
who know him I've never
heard anybody say negative things about
him on the center-left let me see this
gentleman yeah you're gonna know oh yeah
that guy before
how I did was the president to me yeah
it looks like a president to me too you
know who else looks like a president to
me Oh Andrew yang I'm down with that
okay so like what you're saying now good
so here's my point
them guys together those two is that
camera on yes Admiral your country needs
you
it really does never more than now and I
know that the job of president is a
sucky one I'm sure the job of vice
presidents even worse but please
consider this plan because the Republic
is in jeopardy now we already know that
Andrew Yang is up for the job because he
ran for her office yeah you know faced
appallingly stupid obstacles that in my
opinion may in be the reason that he's
not the nominee so here we got two
people one of them I think will do so
out of duty the other is crazy enough to
want the job in the first place and what
are they well they're both Patriots
they're both courageous and they're both
highly capable this is the road out I
don't know the Navy SEAL gentleman but
Raven McRaven but Andrew yang has some
really good ideas yeah I mean and
reasonable ideas across the board and
when in terms of many things not just
universal basic income which was the
thing that he was most popular for but
but even law enforcement he's got some
great ideas about a lot of things he
thinks outside the box a brilliant guy
open to anything yes I'm sorry
reasonable so I would suggest one last
part of the plan right which is that we
Americans have to get over the idea that
when somebody runs for office especially
the office of the president that the
right reaction is to ask them a million
questions about what they will do in
office what policies they advocate
this is absurd presidents don't make
policy they certainly influence what
policy is made but the important thing
about a president is that they listen to
the right sorts of people and that they
have a mind capable of processing what
they hear so that they can integrate the
information necessary and in the case of
this plan we're talking about two people
who would do that as a team so what I
would really be interested in as they
are running against Trump and Biden is
hearing who it is that they would bring
into an administration how would they
make decisions about the things that
matter to us and figuring out who they
would bring in I think is bound to be
far more informative than dogging them
about you know what they're gonna do
about health care and how they're gonna
pay for the thing about asking someone
what they're going to do though is it
does influence people whether or not
they're willing to vote for that person
they want to see a plan I know what
you're saying is a reasonable person who
understands the system but for the
average American they do want to see a
plan to how to get out of a lot of the
messes that we see well you know the
funny thing is we think a lot of things
are true about what people want for one
thing we've been told that people are
stupid and that you know they're
hopeless and if you know I mean you're
really one of the earliest innovators
here you have found that people that
we've been told have an attention span
so short that they can only deal with a
sitcom are interested in a three-hour
conversation about complex topics with
people from all over the map right
people are ready to listen and what I'm
trying to say is we have a wrong idea
right in our in our sense of what
elections are and really that wrong idea
isn't even about the fact that we think
we want to hear the plan it's about the
fact that we know that our power in the
system is so limited that the only way
we could possibly exert any influence on
the policy that gets made is if we can
get somebody to promise us something
into a camera enough that they're
embarrassed not to do it when they get
an office and we also know that doesn't
work right so you know they just do
whatever they're gonna do in ranch place
so my point would be look I will I will
literally vote for any competent
courageous Patriot I actually don't care
in what direction there
yes I would prefer that they were
progressive because I believe we need to
make progress or we will perish but any
courageous capable patriot is good
enough because a courageous capable
Patriot will do way better than we are
doing with the current method
[Applause]